of all the cosmic heroes roaming around
the spaceways of the Marvel Universe
none have ever been as prominent as the
Silver Surfer created by Jack Kirby in
the pages of Fantastic Four he made his
first appearance as The Herald of the
world devouring Galactus and would grow
to become one of the biggest cult
favorites on Marvel's roster from his
unlikely origins to his surprising
prominence in cartoons and even video
games here's the real truth behind
Norrin Radd the Silver Surfer the coming
of Galactus in 1966 Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby plotted a story for Fantastic Four
in which an unstoppable cosmic threat
showed up to devour the world when Kirby
turned in the pages for Fantastic Four
number 48 though Stan was surprised to
find that they featured a chrome-plated
spaceman flying around on a surfboard
Kirby explained that Galactus was such a
big deal that he needed a herald to
announce his presence and since surfing
was all over pop culture in the 60s from
the Beach Boys to Batman his new
character wound up on a cosmic surfboard
Lee was initially wary of adding
something so weird into the middle of a
high-stakes superhero drama but it
worked in a time when most of Marvel's
competitors were still filling every
issue with two or three stories the
coming of Galactus kicked off a modern
multi-part epic with its title villain
only showing up on the last page the
rest of the issue was devoted to the
watcher in the Silver Surfer
assuring readers that have characters
this powerful were the opening act
Galactus must be a truly big deal the
silver symbolism the initial fan
reaction to the surfer was more than a
little divisive as the letters rolled
into the Marvel offices in 1966 some
readers commented that Silver Surfer is
a corny name while one rode in with an
angry screed saying why why don't you
give the Fantastic Four a person a
single person to fight and not a bunch
of space bums running around cluttering
up the yarn and making the pages look
utterly disgraceful ouch
others were a little more kind but the
strangest commentary came from a Houston
Texas reader named Greg Jones Galactus
represents the Vietcong the powerful
aggressor but not realizing fully his
error the Silver Surfer as America
helped a lesser people in their time
need even though he himself was not
involved and Alicia characterized Stan
marveled the president and all other
loyal patriotic Americans needless to
say that's a pretty wild interpretation
of a story about a space giant with a
big hat trying to eat the planet even
Stanley seems surprised by this one
writing
we can't thought an eye without someone
reading some deep subliminal message
into it the surfer goes solo despite his
initial concerns Lee clearly took a
liking to the surfer by the end of that
first story likely because he allowed
Stan to explore the kind of sci-fi
storytelling that he pursued before
getting into comics joined by artist
John Newsome Oh Lee launched a series
that would detail the surfers exile on
earth they revealed that he was Norrin
Radd a would-be victim of Galactus
hunger who gave up his humanity to
become a herald for the devourer of
worlds it represents some of Stan's best
work of the era with more philosophical
stories and the other action-packed
tales he was scripting at the time I
made him a philosophical observer of the
world and the universe there were
however a few problems for one thing the
book just didn't sell
despite Stan's personal investment in
the series and the surfer status as a
cult favorite the original series ended
after only 18 issues even worse it
deepened the rift between Lee and the
surfers creator Jack Kirby who had a
completely different idea for what kind
of stories to tell we attempted to make
amends by bringing Herbie and to tell
the story of a more savage surfer who
would act as cosmic power personified
but that story never happened it was
announced to come next month in that
final issue of the series later that
year Kirby would leave Marvel for DC in
the promise of more creative control
summing up his reasons with the simple
statement I'm not going to give them
another Silver Surfer now you're playing
with the power cosmic given Stanley's
affection for the surfer it's no
surprise that Marvel to get behind more
than a few attempts to bring him to mass
media there was a well-received but
short-lived cartoon in 1998 but in 1990
the surfer made his video game debut on
the Nintendo Entertainment System to
give you an idea of where he ranked the
only other Marvel games on the NES at
the time started the x-men and the
Punisher two of the most popular
franchises of the era he even managed to
beat spider-man to his NES debut by two
full years
magic warriors Mephisto Emperor rectal
in the regular silent is fine Silver
Surfer and fluffy stories unfortunately
being early doesn't always mean being
great while it boasted some pretty
incredible graphics and a killer
soundtrack Silver Surfer is mostly
remembered for a staggering difficulty
level that kept almost everyone who
played it from actually beating the game
if they had though they would have been
treated to a pretty bizarre plot
dispatched on a mission of cosmic
importance by Galactus the Silver Surfer
faces foes like Mephisto and Fire Lord
the final boss though is mr. sinister
and x-men foe with no real connection of
cosmic side of the Marvel Universe who
is depicted as a 15-foot tall purple
Hulk with a handgun and a pair of white
go-go boots maybe it's for the best that
nobody ever got to see him I shall give
to that future okay weirdo the cinematic
rise and fall of the Silver Surfer in
1979 after Superman had become a massive
box-office success
Hollywood was suddenly very interested
in superhero movies in an attempt to get
Marvel a foothold in the film industry
Stan Lee spent a year in Los Angeles
shopping around various projects
including a Silver Surfer pitch it was
picked up too but despite being assigned
a respectable twenty five million dollar
budget and having Olivia newton-john
attached a star the surfer never managed
to escape to the big screen 28 years
later he'd finally make it thanks to
2007's Fantastic Four rise of the Silver
Surfer as the title implies there were
hints at plans to spend the skywriter of
the spaceways off into his own
big-screen adventure unfortunately that
film's failure at the box office put it
into that and two plans for a third FF
movie that would have potentially
involved the scrolls and the Inhumans
showing up in 2015 Marvel's first family
was rebooted with another movie that
landed with an even more resounding thud
managing to perform even worse than its
predecessors but with 35 years of Marvel
trying to bring the surfer to the big
screen it's easy to look at rise of the
Silver Surfer as a mere setback rather
than the final nail in the coffin the
success of cosmic focused films like
guardians of the galaxy and the surfers
provenance and stories like the original
Infinity Gauntlet mean that it's not too
unlikely that we'll see Norrin Radd
surfing his way into the MCU someday
dedicated fans are waiting thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]